Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Oğlum iki buçuk yaşında,
yüzümü kendisine doğru döndürdü
ve "Baba lütfen benimle konuşurken
gözlerimin içine bak," dedi.
Çok şey öğreniyoruz çocuklardan.
Hatta eminim siz de bir
sorunla karşılaştığınız zaman,
çocuk kalbinizle
bakabildiğiniz zaman o soruna
daha özgün, daha güzel
çözümler üretiyorsunuzdur.
Benim sunumuma şöyle bakın:
1. Çocuklardan öğrendiklerim.
2. Çocuk kalbimle bakabildiğim
zaman fark ettiklerim,
belli bir ölçüde geliştirdiklerim.
3. Gelecek nesillerin
bana gönderdiği bazı fikirler.
Sorunumuz var,
sorunumuz şiddet ve tutarsızlık.
Sistem bozuk, bu şekilde devam etmeyecek.
Gece yarısı mı demiştim?
Aslında kıyamete iki dakika kaldı.
Size soracağım;
neden, neleri hangi hikâyeleri
kabul edip de buraya geldik diye.
Eminim kalbinizde cevapları biliyorsunuz.
Ancak zihnimizde bir sis perdesi var,
onu kaldırmak için çalışacağım.
"Sen kimsin ki Hakan?"
diye sorabilirsiniz.
Lise sonrası uzun seneler
yurt dışında okudum ve çalıştım.
Her seferinde faydam
dokunabilir diye geri geldim.
Hatta bu topraklar,
bu geniş coğrafya iyi olmadan
dünyanın geri kalanı
iyi olmayacak diye inanarak.
2000 yılında Türkiye'nin bilişimle
kalkınmasını tarif eden bir proje yazdım.
Dört sene sonra da bu projenin hayata
geçmesini sağlayabilir diye düşündüğüm
çocuk ve gençler için olan
bilimsel turnuvalarla tanıştım.
O gün bugündür bu proje
üstünde her gün çalışıyorum.
Bu sene 1.500'e erişen gönülden biriyim.
Bilginiz olsun diye her sene
patent başvuruları oluyor,
her sene dünyanın
en iyi üniversitelerinden
burs kazanan öğrencilerimiz oluyor.
Şükrediyorum, harika,
muhteşem çalışanlarımız,
gönüllülerimiz
ve destekçilerimiz sayesinde
bu topraklarla ilgili bazı
hayallerimi gerçekleştirebildim.
Onun dışında normal yurdum insanıyım
hatalarımla, eksiklerimle diyorum.
İnsanlık olarak bir krizden geçiyoruz,
tabii ki benim de kendi
krizlerim var, oldu ve oluyor.
Krizlerime sabır ve nezaketle
ve kararlılıkla yaklaştığım zaman
bazı çözümleri üretebildiğimi,
krizi fırsata dönüştürebileceğimi
fark ettim.
Konuşmamda da insanlığın krizine
bu şekilde yaklaşmaya çalışacağım
ve bir çeşit ayna olmak istiyorum.
Bir çeşit ayna olmak istiyorum
ve krize yaklaşırken sorunlarımızı
en geniş evrensel bakış açısından,
en dar kendimize doğru,
7 basamaklı bir yol izleyeceğim.
Evrene uyum, ilk başlığım.
Evrene uyumda tavırlarımız ilk sorunumuz.
Bildiğiniz gibi, fark ettiğiniz gibi
evren birleştiriyor ve üretiyor.
Kadın artı erkek, eşittir çocuk.
Biz ise ayırıp tüketiyoruz.
İrademizle birleştirmek yerine;
rastlantı olan inanç, ırk, cinsiyet,
renk, dil gibi kavramları kullanıp
birbirimizi kategorize ediyoruz.
Gelecekteki çatışmaların
tohumlarını atıyoruz.
Suç ortağı oluyoruz
aslında bizi susturuyorlar,
kimlik siyaseti yaparak bizi
susturuyorlar, bahaneler üretiyorlar.
Üretilen bahaneler genellikle
"ama" kelimesiyle başlıyor
veya "ama onlar da yaptı."
Bu kelimeler, bahaneler bizi kitliyor.
Kullanılması gereken insanlığın
en kadim bilgilerinden altın kural,
yani "Komşuna, diğerine, kendine
davranılmasını istediğin gibi davran,"
kuralını unutmuş kişi,
kurul ve siyasi iradeler var
neredeyse dünyanın her yerinde.
Bu ikinci konum,
birleştirici mesaj meselesi.
Bilim dünyada en birleştirici kavram
fakat hiçbir siyasetçi dünyada bilimi
birleştirici kavram olarak kullanmıyor.
Birleştiricilikten kastım şu;
bakınız cep telefonu,
7 milyar insanı birleştiriyor
fakat hiçbir siyasetçi bunu kullanmıyor
çünkü kimlik siyaseti bizim
ilkel duygularımızı tetikleyip
daha ucuza oy kazandırıyor.
Üçüncü konum, evrensel değerler.
Zannediyoruz ki
kullandığımız değerler evrensel.
Bunun testini şu şekilde yapabilirsiniz:
Başka gezegende yaşam olsa
sizin evrensel dediğiniz değerler
orada da geçerli olur mu?
Benim teklifim bugünlük dürüstlük.
Olacağını düşünüyorum
ama siz de kendi
değerlerinizi test edebilirsiniz.
Neyse evrensel olmayan değerler,
ne yazık ki bizi ayırıyor
ve evreni uyumsuz kılıyor.
İkinci başlık, gezegene uyum konusu.
Kirletiyoruz, kim temizleyecek
diye düşünmüyoruz.
Gezegeni çocuklarımızdan
ödünç aldığımızı unutmuşuz.
Bir başka konu fosil yakıtlar;
petrol, doğalgaz, kömürü ele alırsak
bunlar hazırı yediğimiz konular.
Tekrar kendiliğinden oluşması
bir milyon ile yüz milyon yıl alıyor.
Yani biz gezegenden
ve gelecek nesillerden çalıyoruz.
Reel ekonominin en önemli girdisinin
bir çeşit hırsızlık yoluyla
olduğu bir dünyada,
bir konumda, biz şu andaki
krizimizi tanımlamaya çalışıyoruz.
Diğer bir başlık, fiyatlar.
Gayet nötr gibi gözüküyor fiyat kavramı.
Bu ekonomik kavram
gerçek maliyetleri yansıtmıyor.
Yani gezegene yapılan, verilen zararın
maliyeti hiçbir zaman fiyata dahil değil
veya neredeyse hiçbir
zaman fiyata dahil değil.
Yediğiniz hamburgerin fiyatında
o sığırın yetişmesini sağlayan
suyun miktarı dahil değil,
çıkardığı metan gazının
gezegene verdiği zarar dahil değil.
Bir diğer konumuz, ağaçlar ve hayvanlar.
Ağaçları yok ediyoruz, rant için kesiyoruz
ama aslında biliyoruz, ormanlar olmasa
bizim ilaç olarak kullanabileceğimiz
birçok hammadde olmayacak.
Hayvanları sömürüyoruz,
öldürmek için yetiştiriyoruz,
işkence gibi şartlarda saklıyoruz,
yok ediyoruz, taşıyoruz
ve bu vahşetteki sorumluluğumuzun
bizim gelecek nesillerimize,
bizim çocuklarımıza
vahşetin kabul edilebilir bir şey
olduğunu aktardığının farkında değiliz.
İnsanlığa uyumsuzuz.
Bunu iki başlıkta ele alacağım.
Bir tanesi, şiddet her yerde diyorum.
Duymuş olabilirsiniz,
Birleşmiş Milletler'in sürdürülebilir
kalkınma hedefleri var.
Bunlar 17 maddelik bir tablo.
Bu 17 maddeyi sıkıştırsam
3 başlıkta özetlerim:
1. Dengesizlik var;
gelir dengesizliği,
yaşam kalitesi dengesizliği
ve ekolojik dengesizlikler.
Bunları da da sıkıştırsam,
sorunumuz şiddet.
Şiddeti zaman zaman gezegene uyguluyoruz,
zaman zaman da birbirimize.
2. başlık: Sembolik bir kıyamet saati.
Duymuş olabilirsiniz,
Chicago Üniversitesi'ndeki bilim insanları
1947'den beri aslında nükleer
savaşa kalınan dakika olarak
ölçmeye başlamış oldukları
kıyamete kalan süreyi ölçüyorlar.
Ocak 2018 güncellemesi
iki dakika kaldığını gösteriyor,
1991'de 17 dakika varmış.
Ülkedaşlara uyumsuzuz.
Gelir, adalet, güven,
ahbap çavuş kapitalizmi,
liyakat, şeffaflık, yolsuzluk,
kayırma, güçler ayrılığı,
fikir, ifade özgürlüğü
sorunları çok bariz.
Bunların hepsi şiddetin yansımaları
ancak bir sorunumuz daha var.
Hepimiz geçmişle gelecek
arasında birer köprüyüz.
Atalarımız eğer ülkedaşlarımıza
şiddet uyguladıysa
bununla yüzleşmezsek biz de sorumluyuz,
hatta bu şiddet gelecek nesillere
uygulanan şiddet olarak geri dönüyor.
Dünyanın her ülkesinde,
kendi ülkesinde uygulanan şiddetle
yüzleşmeyen siyasetçiler seçiliyor,
güç kazanıyor ama konumuz
hiçbir zaman sağ-sol değil,
her zaman şiddetin sürmesi veya sürmemesi.
Aile ve arkadaşlarımıza uyumsuzuz.
Ön yargılıyız, yargılıyoruz.
Kendimize acıyoruz,
kurban rolünü oynuyoruz.
Kadına ve çocuklara şiddet uyguluyoruz.
Sadece ülkemizde geçen 10 sene içinde
500 bin çocuk zorla evlendirildi
ve 142 bin çocuk doğum yaptı.
Dilimiz şiddet içeriyor.
Birleştirici, süreç odaklı bir dil yerine;
ayırıcı, sonuç odaklı
bir dil kullanıyoruz.
Sonuç odaklı dilin
kullanılması yine şiddeti besliyor,
hem eğitim sisteminin içinde
hem profesyonel yaşamda.
Erkeğin bir saniyesi,
kadının dokuz ay on günü;
kadınlar, zamanla olan bağımız.
Kadınlarla, çocuklarla barışamayan
bir ülke düşünün,
bu ülkenin zamanla barışması,
başarılı olması mümkün değil.
Kendimizle uyumsuzuz.
Kendimden biliyorum;
uyguladığımız ve bize
uygulanan şiddetin gölgesinde,
kendimizi dinlemek ve tanımak
için vaktimiz yok, sabrımız yok.
Yalan söylüyoruz, maske takıyoruz,
sorumluluk almıyoruz, kaçıyoruz,
kibirliyiz, egomuz var,
şımarıklık, küstahlık bencillik diz boyu.
Fark etmemiz gereken bir şey var,
o da yaşam yalnızca kendi yolculuğumuz.
Bunu fark ettiğimiz anda beklenti ve hayal
kırıklıklarını neredeyse yok ediyoruz
ve kendimizi sevmeye başlıyoruz.
Şair demiş, "Bir insanı sevmekle
başlayacak her şey," diye.
Belki de sevmemiz gereken
insan ilk önce biziz.
Daha iyi bir gelecekle bugün arasındaki
belki en önemli engel kendimiziz
ama sorumluluk alıp da devam edersek
belki ihtiyacımız olan
tek kahraman yine biziz.
Özetle, geçmişinle yüzleş,
kendini sev, sarıl, sorumluluk al,
birleştirici, süreç odaklı dili kullan,
kadınları çocukları onore et,
aile ve dostlarına sarıl,
köprü olduğunu hatırlayıp kimliği ne
olursa olsun her ülkedaşına sarıl,
onore et, yaygın şiddeti ortadan
kaldırmak için her gün çalış,
ağaçları hayvanları gezegeni koru,
evrensel değerleri kullan,
bilimi rehber edin,
altın kuralı uygula ki
kıyamet saatini geri sarabilelim,
yaşam kalitesi artsın diye çalışabilelim
ve gelecek nesillerin gözlerinin
içine gerçekten bakabilelim.
Zihnimizdeki sis perdesini
kaldırıp ayna olmaya çalıştım.
Bu bahsettiğim değişim
içeriden dışarı olmalı,
reçetem uzun, umutsuz gelebilir
ancak son 14 senedir binlerce çocuk gördüm
ve anlatmaya çalıştığım şey çok basit,
çocuklar anlattığım noktadalar.
Yeter ki biz yanlış bir şey yapmayalım.
Soruna ve krize yaklaşımı
insanlık üstünden,
evrensel parametrik
bir şekilde yapmaya çalıştım.
Amacım gerçekten birleştirmek.
Farklı açıdan bakarsak
belki her gezegen iç barışına erişirken
benzeri bir süreçten geçiyordur diyeceğim.
Kalk zilimiz çalıyor,
gelecek nesiller gözlerimizin
içine umutla bakıyor.
İki dakikamız, bir kalbimiz var.
Sizin kalbiniz ne yapmamızı istiyor?
(Alkış)